Dr. Bock, if you could please introduce yourself with your name in today's state in our location.
My name is John Block, today's date is August 5th, 2014, and we are in the family room of my house.
And we're going to talk a bit about your career and pharmacy and your association with OSU.
We want to start off at the beginning. You were born in Yakima, Washington.
That is correct. Is that where you were raised?
Yes, all the way through high school and then Washington State University for bachelor's degrees and master's and university Wisconsin and Madison for my doctorate.
What were your parents backgrounds?
You mean business-wise, education-wise, what does it give us a sense of view?
Well, my mother was born and raised in Yakima. It's a funny story. Her parents were in probably the last group of pioneers.
They're actually listed in the Yakima Valley Historical Museum on some wall plaque.
They actually came out in a pioneer train. They were on a wagon train.
She was raised there and born on a farm. I think my granddad was a foreman or something like that. It was not his farm.
And the interesting thing was her birth was never registered because she was a girl baby born out on a farm.
And I was not pertinent later on after she was married to my dad who I mentioned just a moment. They got a court order.
But hers was a court order birth certificate which then paid off when Medicare came along because she could prove her age.
My dad was raised in Buffalo, New York.
And in those days, there was no State University in New York per se.
They were the State of New York supported different majors at private schools. So I think forestry was at Syracuse, engineering was at Cornell, things like that.
And he was a twin. And second born, he had an older brother and his dad being German.
Said the oldest son was the one who's going to get to go to college. So my dad took commercial courses.
And in the senior year in high school, his dad, my granddad, told him whether there was enough money for him to go to college.
Well, my dad sort of said he didn't take the college trip courses so he was not eligible for any New York school.
So he went to the University of Pennsylvania, graduated from the Wharton School of Business Administration.
As my dad said before Harvard stole the faculty, hired onto the Firestone Tire and Rubber Company.
And Harvey Firestone with Junior was in his training class.
And then as he looked for a position to be a Firestone Tire salesman, he found that the Eastern Washington, or actually the Central Washington District, had done very poorly.
And he had been advised, don't replace every tiring salesman who was real successful because you'll go down, go to one that is not successful as you can go up.
And he was, he was successful. And he, Basie, I think was headquarter in Yakima, but his territory taken all through the Eastern Washington.
And they small wheat towns, colitis, wash, techno. I guess over the coal facts, maybe up to Spokane that I'm not sure.
My mother, I guess they were going to a baseball game somewhere and got married.
Drove a Model A Ford for their Wharton trip back to Buffalo, which is where he was then going to work. He resigned from Firestone.
And as they've gone, I guess into Canada crossing Detroit, Windsor, then into Canada, then across the Peace Bridge, into Buffalo.
And the immigration customs guy on the U.S. side, of course, asked who they were, where they were born.
And my dad said he was born in Buffalo fine. My mother was very naive and said she was born in Yakima.
He asked her what part of Japan was that. And she didn't have a birth certificate as I indicated.
Well then, so he got in, obviously. Depression struck.
And what people didn't realize was that depression was roughest in the industrial parts of the United States,
because the manufacturing stopped, the people were all laid off.
And the rural areas, things weren't great, but people ate and they bartered.
So my dad decided we're going to head back out to the state of Washington.
And he had business contacts who could help him get established.
And so that's how he got back west, left Buffalo, and got going in Yakima on.
Basically, Billupman and a fuel oil gasoline distribution business.
Fuel oil before natural gas had come in.
Did you have any siblings?
I had my brother died a couple of years ago. He was eight years older than me.
And I said he died a couple of years ago.
He graduated from Washington State also, ROTC, back in the days of the Korean War.
And of course, remember there was a draft on.
And stayed in the military.
Got to be a bird kernel.
And so actually I attended and participated in his internment in Arlington with the full case on,
banned the whole ceremony.
What were you just screwing up as a boy in Yakima?
Well, that's interesting.
I guess I dabbled around in photography.
I had a dark room.
With shoot pictures.
I had a 30-fold Argus C-335 millimeter camera.
I graduated from a Brownie, Kodak Brownie.
And with development pictures, I never did do color.
I did family photo Christmas cards.
Took some of the pictures around the church I grew up in.
And got on the, I was, got on the stage crew at Yakima.
Those days was Yakima Senior High School.
It was the only high school in town in those days.
And it was also the city auditorium.
It had a beautiful, a nice auditorium, full stage,
dressing rooms in the basement.
And we would be, those are the stage crew.
If we worked for a somebody putting a show on, we would get paid.
So I got finally a response position.
I even got a key to the stage area.
And learned how to get along with the janitors.
So I was on the stage crew when the Air Force band came through.
And there was a stage circus with a little baby elephant in the basement.
That upset the janitor because he made a mess.
And of course, there were the plays and things like that that were put on.
How much of your early interest in science or in pharmacy?
I guess it was just the science courses that we had to take curriculum in those days
when I was pretty regimented in high school.
And well, even I come out of the era of junior high.
So grade school went through sixth grade.
Junior high was seventh through ninth.
And high school was tenth, eleventh, and twelfth grades.
And had very good science teachers.
They all had a master's degree.
It's pretty much in their science and their subject matter,
as opposed to a master's of teaching.
And I guess that was how I got my interest.
I didn't pick pharmacy right away.
I went as an undeclared major at Washington state and hunted around
and went to the counseling center.
And sort of looked bad.
And I thought, well, you kind of had the pre-farmacy curriculum
as what I was doing.
And it was one where I didn't think I'd be stuck in a lab.
I would know the public well, I ended up in a lab anyway,
off to grad school and academia.
Well, tell me about your experience at Washington state
as an undergrad in the budding pharmacist.
Well, we lived in...
There were two political parties in those days.
There were the Greeks and the independence.
And there was none of this that freshman lived in the dorms
their first year.
If you pledge, you went to your Greek house immediately.
The person who was in charge of the dorms believed in a strong dorm system
and loyalty and so forth.
So if you went in Greek by golly, you went to your fraternity or sorority for the women.
And of course, there was no such thing as co-ed dorms.
The boys were on one side of the campus
and the girls on the other side of the campus.
And if you didn't get the girl in on certain times,
you got a campus and you had to give her a dozen roses,
which happened to me once.
And the dorm I was in was nice.
They were sweets of rooms.
They had washbasins in the rooms.
There weren't the long hallways.
It was...
I won't call it semi-private, but they were nice.
And they were quiet.
They had real thick walls between the rooms.
So plaster on a lathe.
So it was good.
And we had a good reputation.
We got one of the higher grade point averages.
There was this type of competition and intermural,
which I didn't participate in.
My worst sport in school was PE.
Just as an aside, you'll never guess who my high school...
One of my two high school physical education instructors
were Bobo Brayton before he went off to Washington State
to be the famous baseball coach.
He was a high school PE teacher.
What was the curriculum like for you in pharmacy as an undergrad?
I have seen it was somewhat different from what students do.
It was...
Well, we had compounding.
It had a lot more lab involved.
And so I said,
we'd compounded ointments and creams and suspensions
and elixirs and all that type of stuff.
Otherwise, medicinal chemistry was medicinal chemistry
based on what was known those days.
Pharmacology was pharmacology.
Pharmacidics was pharmaceuticals.
It just...
There wasn't as much known.
The concept of a receptor was just that,
a receptor.
It had never been one,
it had never been isolated.
Drug design was in its infancy.
It was basically a group of compounds
and the companies would screen them.
And if they got a hit, they got a hit.
The key fobver amendments had not yet passed.
So you had to tell it a might situation occurred.
I'm trying to remember when the efficacy requirements went in
and they screened all the over-the-counter drugs
and reform laid a lot of them because the brands were popular
but they had to take ingredients out
because they couldn't prove they were effective.
So I would say the science and the efficacy requirements
have greatly increased over the years.
And now, there of course into all the re-evaluate
and the type of statistics that are used
and how much are the companies.
And I don't mean as an anti-company thing at all
because I'm sure some of the same stuff went on the lab
and the university labs too.
I'll just look at the number of papers that are being retracted
nowadays coming out at university labs
and institutes and so forth.
But when you throw out a bad study,
when we were out at the bad study,
it was probably a very important study that said something
you better be alert to.
So I would say there's a lot more in the stay-in-age
of electronic and communication and so forth.
Anyways, the public may be better protected.
The time that you'd finished the Washington State,
it was pretty clear you were going to be a farmer
since it seems.
What about it, appeal to you?
What was your, sparked your interest, I suppose,
in pursuing career in pharmacy?
Well, I knew I could not do medicine
because you'll notice I'm holding my hands here
and there's a slight tremor.
I have what's called familial or idiopathic tremor
and hair different grandmother through mother through me.
And at least in medical school in those days,
there was a required surgical rotation.
And you would not want me to be your surgeon.
And in fact, in physiology,
we had to do surgeries on rabbits
and we all had to take turns.
And I didn't do too well in my rabbit.
Unfortunately, I had three other people on the team
that could bail me out.
But I was one of those kids in grade school
when testing the measurement came along first grade.
I couldn't get my bow tied on my shoe.
I'm real clueless with my hands.
So you didn't want me in medicine at all
or dentistry or anything like that.
But I can count or lick and stick.
I mean, which is, of course,
and convey knowledge to the customer or the client.
But the follow-up later became Dean at Washington State
looked at my record and said,
basically, I think you ought to consider graduate school.
So that's just a faculty member took an interest.
So you had to put me off in that direction.
You had to mentor a source of that.
Oh, definitely.
Definitely.
Well, you went to Wisconsin briefly after Washington State.
Well, I was there for four years.
Right.
But did you do some post-grad work at Wisconsin
right after you finished your bachelor's degree?
Am I right about that?
After my bachelor's degree,
and I stayed at Washington State to get my master's.
And then went to Wisconsin.
And I was there for four years in a difficult period of time
to get a doctorate,
at least in the chemical-like pharmacy sciences, came here.
So I graduated in, basically, 1966.
Tell me about your graduate training.
Washington State was in Wisconsin.
Washington State was a traditional,
I mean, for the masters was a traditional medicinal chemistry
had a research problem,
make a series of compounds.
And I wasn't there for them to be tested.
But that was basically it.
And, of course, you take the appropriate chemistry courses
with, in fact, most of the courses were in chemistry,
except for an advanced course in drug design.
At Wisconsin,
did you want me to jump to Wisconsin?
Yeah, one of you ready?
Okay.
At Wisconsin, again, they didn't have a course.
It was interesting.
I was really going to work for a different chemist.
And he moved on to Kansas.
And I say, I ended up at Wisconsin.
And that's an interesting story.
Okay.
God will be able to have a lot of inches on your,
I guess it's no longer inches on the table.
It's a silicate chip.
And there it is.
Right.
I applied to three different graduate school,
or I wrote to three different graduate schools
and applied to two, if I remember right.
I told you the person I was interested in at Wisconsin
had moved to Kansas University of Kansas at Lawrence.
But they sent me old outdated catalogs.
So I just shrugged it off.
I had, there were a couple new faculty members
at Washington State who were both Wisconsin grads.
So I was sort of getting input from them at the same time.
And they knew the personalities of Wisconsin.
I applied to the University of California at San Francisco,
which is where the pharmacy, that's the medical center
of the University of California.
The original medical center for the University of California
is system there more than one now.
And applied there and was accepted with a teaching assistantship.
I got accepted at the University of Wisconsin
with a research assistantship.
And they, these two fellow faculty assistant presses
has grabbed the research assistantship
and you can start right out near research
and speed things along.
So I did.
And it was very interesting.
In late spring, I got a letter from the University of California,
San Francisco.
San, they would award me a Smith Klein and French fellowship.
I think probably I was a runner-up
and whoever they originally gave it to turned it down
and went somewhere else.
But by that time I had made my choice
and it didn't seem right to back down.
Very few when I'd accepted.
And it would have actually been unethical for California
to accept it me then.
I don't think they would have cared.
But it turned out well.
I got my doctorate.
I met my wife this December.
It would be our 50th wedding anniversary.
So it worked out well at Wisconsin.
Tell me about the environment there.
How it was different from what Washington State?
Oh.
Wisconsin was definitely a research university.
It was definitely publisher parish for the faculty.
The undergrad, as the former dean told me on my exit interview,
he said, you want to understand the role of the undergraduate.
They provide the tuition and support
so that you faculty can do your research.
So treat them nicely.
I mean, that was, I know there are fans and butts about it.
You've got to keep in mind Wisconsin had a longer tradition
that a lot of the big 10 schools,
because they had to Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation.
So when you drink your glass of milk with vitamin D in it,
the royalties from that patent that's gone to the University of Wisconsin.
And if you are using warframe as an antiquite on her rat poison,
the warface Wisconsin Alumni Research Foundation,
that was all discovered at Wisconsin.
And on it goes.
So they were in the business full-time,
a known mistake about it.
And a lot of us sort of had a reaction too,
like do we want to be a system of professors in this type of environment?
So when the opportunity came to come to Oregon State,
it seemed nice attractive because there was more emphasis on the teaching.
Well, before we get to see how I'm interested a little bit more
in your research as a graduate student, how I progressed.
Well, it went well.
I got publications.
It was a different type of problem.
It was not a drug design problem.
My major professor was actually in the natural products.
And he was very successful at it.
But he had a, what was called a physical organic problem.
He made his claim to fame by, actually, I think finding an error
and a structure that the late RB Woodward developed that was just,
the only error was in the stereo chemistry.
But anyway.
So he wanted to follow up on that.
And so basically that was my problem.
So I did not have to do natural products isolate
and hope I got everything done with the 10 milligrams
that could get out of the plant.
I could just keep making my comp, my simple little compound
and keep running tests on him so forth.
So it was that type of problem.
But otherwise it was a standard graduate,
university graduate, chemistry lab.
Lab benches.
Everybody in there working postdocs and graduate students.
We came to OSU in 1966.
It's only a bit about the decision to move back to Oregon.
It was mainly jobs were kind of tight academic jobs.
I had a chance to interview at the chemical abstract service
at the American Chemical Society as the parent of it in Columbus, Ohio.
And I could tell that was all going to get computerized at some point.
And I thought that would be a good mix.
And I think I would have done well.
But this other position came along.
And I talked to a major professor and decided to take it.
So it turned out that there was an opening also at the University of Nebraska,
which I guess I really wasn't that aware of.
But a person I later knew and he and I became co-authors
on the first textbook I was involved with.
And he said, oh yeah, he knew about the, I don't know what you'll read, God is PhD.
But he knew about the Oregon position.
And later heard it was got filled.
He didn't realize it was me until later we met with comparing notes.
And I'm glad it took Oregon because things have not gone well for pharmacy in Nebraska.
They were in Lincoln.
And then they got moved to the medical center in Omaha.
And the provost of Moody was all very pro.
Then Nebraska start half financial problems.
There were two pharmacy schools in Omaha.
And the governor said, you know, I need one.
And why don't we let Creighton be it?
I don't know what he was still against having one of the state school.
But anyway, so they had budgets cut.
They had a school, but when budgets cuts like that happen
and good faculty aren't going to go there and some leave,
that would not have been a good situation.
This has been a growth situation.
And the pharmacy school here has grown professionally.
And enrollment too, but professionally.
What were your initial impressions of the university of Corralis?
Well, Corralis was a nice beautiful college town even.
I shouldn't say even in those days.
And I like the fact I could even bicycle.
I had a bicycle from Wisconsin.
The interview was weird.
I have to say because my colleagues at Madison were going for their various interviews
and talking about these research presentations they had to give and all this.
And I come out here and there was no affirmative action.
None of that type of stuff.
I was hiring the backseat of the Dean's car.
At the townhouse, Motel.
After 24 hours of interview.
So anyway, things were...
I thought, well, this is good. I like this.
So I had a job.
And my wife fortune's very flexible.
And she had gone to school out of state and so forth as far as her bachelor's and traveled quite a bit.
So she was fine.
And she's enjoyed this town too very, very much so.
Climate wise, it's superior to the winners of Wisconsin.
And then you have the hot muggy summers with the mosquitoes and Wisconsin.
So, no, this is a very pleasant place to live.
How would you characterize the department upon your arrival?
Very heavy teach and orientate oriented and very, very structured.
It was a small faculty. It was...
No data, I believe it was a school of pharmacy.
And then I think under President Wicker...
It got to be Oregon State University.
It was not Oregon State College.
A time I got here was Oregon State University.
And some of the academic units were colleges and some were still schools.
And he finally said, look, I guess he told the deans, I guess.
I wasn't.
That if you want to be a college, you can be a college.
So I guess we changed our glider head.
We became a college.
And that meant we had departments.
And the...
But the word that, I mean, medicinal chemistry,
had a department head and two faculty.
Pharmacidics had a department head and three faculty.
Pharmacology had a department head and two faculty.
It was crazy.
And I think there was a department of pharmacology,
which is the old term for natural products.
And I think they had two faculty.
And so the deans didn't have faculty meetings.
This was Charlie Wilson.
He had department head meetings.
And so these four sort of senior guys sort of ran the school
and the rest of it sort of picked up by osmosis.
What the heck was going on.
I never had a faculty meeting once in a while.
So...
Was there any sense of the history of the program
that had been around since 1898?
No.
And in your research, you...
Whatever you can find.
And I don't mean this negatively, but...
There was a former dean named was Clausson.
And he committed suicide.
And I actually had a graduate student who was an undergraduate here
at the time that occurred.
I don't, to this day, know exactly what the situation.
I obviously had depression of some type.
And there was some story that he had run up gambling debts and so forth.
But I honestly don't know the truth.
To his credit, he was a Minnesota grad, as I understand it.
And he brought one of the first Rokai Rokai's
a National Pharmacy Honor Society.
Toregan State, I remember what chapter we are.
But we're one of the very early chapters.
Is it a Phi Delta Phi?
No, no. Phi Delta Phi is a pharmacy fraternity, co-ed.
There's no one called Kapasai, that I was a member of.
No, no. Rokai Rx.
And there used to be a women's sorority.
I think it's fallen by the wayside.
Well, I know it has an Oregon state.
And there were a faculty who were Phi Delta Chi who wanted...
That's why basically Phi Delta Chi.
There used to be both Phi Delta Chi and Kapasai.
Kapasai fell by the wayside and Phi Delta Chi has been the predominant.
And I'm not sure how active it is anymore.
But Rokai still initiates top students each year.
There is also a leadership group which is fairly new.
And I don't know what it is.
And I think it's Rokai to a joint induction ceremony,
to spring it.
Los Alstoward or CH2M Hill, alumni center,
somewhere like that.
So after Clawson died,
they brought in Charlie Wilson,
who had been at Minnesota,
and was down at Texas.
And he was co-author of a very famous well-established...
became very well-established medicinal chemistry textbook.
It was Wilson and Gisffold.
And Ole Gisffold was also at Minnesota.
They started at Minnesota and it was the first.
So when I had it as an undergraduate even,
and the later got to be multi-authored,
I ended up being a co-editor for a couple years of it,
an author of a chapter or two for one or two editions.
Anyway, he came and his idea...
He was told he was supposed to try to start increasing the research capability.
So he was hiring young faculty out of grad school.
There was a new pharmaceutical person.
He was a pharmacologist.
Got a good grant fairly early.
I never was able to get anything big.
I would get smaller grants.
And the pharmaceutical person went off to the industry.
It was Diagnol Hauser.
There was an addition to the building maintenance.
That was just going on.
When I interviewed, they were in the finishing state.
I came in December for the...
Well, it was the Christmas break.
And in fact, you know how you usually pay
to bring a person out for an interview?
No.
I took my wife to Yakima for the first time at Christmas time.
After Christmas, we drove down to...
I took my...
My mother's car and drove down to Corvallis.
Went through the interview.
And I think I might have got reimbursed for mileage later.
He did pay for staying in a motel on the way back
because there have been quite a bit of snow.
So got me cheap as far as...
There was no this hiring start-up money.
Start-up your lab.
But to answer your question, when I came,
the faculty had...
were scared around campus because of the addition.
When I arrived in September, they were all back in the new building.
And the labs were set up.
And I see that was pretty impactful in these days.
Potentially, yes.
It did start some research going
and they started to see some increase in graduate students.
The...
Oh, the USB Department of Pharmacy Administration with...
maybe one other faculty member in the department that I'm not sure made over to.
There's an interesting story that goes...
Charlie Wilson worked very hard to get that addition put on.
And the ledges...
he got approval and I guess eight...
but those days it definitely had to go through the legislature.
And the new offices were all to be labs
with fume hoods
and the faucets and the gas outlets and so on.
He...
went to NIH.
Money was a lot more plentiful from the federal government those days.
He went to...
and I think it was NIH, make sense.
And got a grant to outfit these offices as labs.
And unbelievable.
The state said, we budgeted X amount of money.
Since you got this federal money,
we're going to subtract the state money.
And so they had...
he sat down the plans and put X's through marking out which lab...
offices could have labs in which ones would not have fume hoods.
Did you get one ahead of life?
I had one ahead of hood, yeah.
Because I was a new young assistant professor.
But, yeah, that's how strange things were in Oregon, for example.
Which department were you in?
Either we were called medicinal chemistry or pharmaceutical chemistry, I forgot which.
At the industrial level, the term pharmaceutical chemistry is what...
it's an academic level we might call pharmaceutical, it's formulation.
And the drug design is in medicinal chemistry.
But in academia,
it's like pharmaceutical chemistry with the drug design area.
So what were your responsibilities in this initial position?
Well, I was very surprised.
I was going to be teaching a lab in medicinal chemistry.
I didn't think there was such a thing left.
So I taught a lab in medicinal chemistry.
Which took a lot of time.
Was this... what do you mean by such a thing that was left as a sort of an older approach to...
Yeah, yes, yes.
Oh yeah, they did various...
So, I build a...
I honestly, gosh, cannot remember where these experiments came from and so forth.
But, we slow...
It took years to get rid of that lab.
I did not teach in the farm.
We had a pharmaceutical analysis course.
And there was a lab in that.
And those labs slowly disappeared as more didactic material got into the course.
I ended up starting the second year.
I taught the biochemistry course.
Because that was my minor at Wisconsin.
And the story on that is very, very interesting.
I see a smile, so maybe you know part of the story.
The dean and one of the other senior faculty had daughters, I think, both daughters,
who were in pharmacy and were really complaining about the quality of instruction
from the Department of Biochemistry.
It used to be biochemistry and now it's biochemistry and bio physics.
And one of the complaints was that each quarter they would keep changing instructors.
And this would happen each year.
So, over in the pharmacy school, you couldn't get a reading on what was being covered
when the students coming in who had had the biochemistry course because there was this rotation
of instructors going on.
It was a service course.
And the pharmacy students would start to complain when they were kind of a cohesive bunch.
And that made the biochemistry faculty angry.
And finally, the dean says, I'm going to yank the course.
Start teaching a John and try to make it unique.
Well, they had a rule in those days.
There was to be no duplication of course work on campus.
And they really got a tight about it.
But I did.
And I started with a course towards a clinical approach and a nutrition approach.
So, I started to change a lot of stuff.
I mean, it was still basic biochemistry.
It still went through intermeanory metabolism.
We still went through protein chemistry.
No labs though.
Chemistry carbohydrates.
And then what was known about DNA and RNA.
And of course that is mushroomed.
But I picked up and started to cover diabetes, biochemistry and diabetes.
The biochemistry of hyperlipidemias.
Before there was much known about hyperlipidemias.
I think everything was cholesterol in those days.
And so on.
And then I wrote a paper for the American Journal of Pharmaceutical Education on a clinical approach to teaching of biochemistry.
Most successful paper ever wrote all my 100 reprints disappeared.
They all got requested.
I gave an oral presentation at the American Association College of Pharmacy.
And it was packed.
I was on a roll.
It was not what you call a research paper.
Well, the chair of biochemistry and another faculty member came over to have a meeting and said,
do we teach that?
Well, they didn't teach that approach.
And they find it up.
And we just want you to know that we teach it too.
But you can go ahead and teach your stuff.
Okay.
I got along actually with most of them over there.
Fine.
We got along.
But every so often.
It would come up.
One of the faculty members is over at Dixon in the dressing room.
And it came up, you know, his faculty members in pharmacy.
And this other, this fellow in biochemistry says,
so how come it is you keep teaching that biochemistry course?
There were the physical chemists in our living room.
My wife was very active with American field service AFS.
And there was a group in our living room.
And the physical organic chemist said,
hold the sun and blurt it out.
You know, you really have no business teaching biochemistry.
It wasn't even his department.
That's really, somewhere along the line.
I had a different reputation, different parts of the campus, I guess.
It's kind of fun.
Particularly once you get 10, you're what they're going to do, you know.
But eventually when we went to the doctor of pharmacy program,
we met with Chris Matthews, a chair of biochemistry.
And basically, they took the course back.
And it was a higher level course that we had the students in,
rather than the service course.
I told him what I was going to continue teaching,
which was the nutritional aspects in some of the diseases.
And they said, fine, can anybody of our students come?
I said, sure.
But I don't think any day we did.
So everything was fine.
My understanding now what they have done is they're only requiring
the first two years, first two, some quarters of biochemistry,
because we're still in the quarter system.
And I'm not sure how they're handling the molecular biology.
It has changed so much.
And with the heavy research emphasis, the faculty are extremely focused
doing their teaching.
And you get such a turnover of faculty going on in the biochemistry.
And that's our courses, too.
There's very rare where you'll see one faculty member.
She's a course from again, and there'll be a course coordinator,
who's basically the job is to make sure the grades get submitted on time
to the registrar.
So there's a lot of this.
You might say it's a medical school model that's going on.
Did it seem that the pharmacy was resistant to change
in terms of the curriculum early on?
No, in fact, just the opposite.
We always had curricular upheavals.
And that was going on nationally, too.
There are all these trends.
You got to change the clinical pharmacy.
You got to do that.
You got to put in communication skills.
You got to put in cultural sensitivities.
Oh, no, no, no.
There's...
It was always in state of flux.
Always going through transitions.
And what do you do about a student who was not right in sequence
in the curriculum changed that?
What do you do for them?
No.
Oh, no.
That's just the opposite.
We were very fluid.
Tell me about setting up your research in OSU.
That got off to a slow start.
I basically had some undergraduates.
And I really had trouble getting going.
I did one based on my PhD and got the paper published.
But I was always fascinated in what's called
my TAS structure activity relationships.
And it's a statistical method of drug design.
And I ended up with a graduate student named Doug Henry,
who was very good at statistics.
And that's basically what Doug is where I got the bulk of my papers.
I had a couple other graduate students who got papers.
But overall, I basically got into the drug design area.
And I was publishing in that area.
And I would go off to the Gordon Research Conference.
I started to get a little bit of money from the Army.
The Army.
And it was not the chemical warfare bunch.
That type.
And go back to their research conferences and did certain things with them.
I mean, published and nothing was classified.
And I made a contact at a Gordon Conference.
So let's say it was that.
So that's the base what I did.
I don't have that many papers.
And I remember really got any real big grants.
I think the biggest ever goes, 10 or 12,000.
Was the model pharmacy, the model drug store still around?
Oh, and I came.
Well, there was a prescription lab.
And they had cubicles.
So the students learned to dispense.
And there was phones.
And some faculty member or grad student
would function as a doctorate point in prescriptions.
So there was still that, yes.
But that's disappeared.
What was your sense of the climate on campus when you arrived
in the 60s, proceeded in that sort of well?
I won't arose.
When I bicycle onto the campus that late September,
first day of classes, there was a group of freshmen in green beanies.
And I was dumbfounded.
I could not believe this.
Because I'd been to Washington State.
It was not such a thing as green.
It was just a regular university.
I could not believe it.
It was a cow college.
It was an ag school.
When I saw the PhD curriculum,
it was loaded with coursework.
And the story goes.
And I have one emphasized story because I never heard it face-to-face.
But the dean of the graduate school in those days believed in lots of coursework.
Because he knew that Oregon State PhD graduates were not going to go
to the big research universities.
They were going to go to the smaller schools and be teachers.
So they need to take a lot of coursework so they could teach a number of subjects.
Oh, well that's interesting.
When, obviously I knew I wanted to get tenured.
And in my third year, I got a letter from the president of the university,
Dr. Jensen, saying,
You have tenured.
I like this.
I like this place.
Okay, I wasn't promoted yet, but I had tenured after three years.
And you don't have to go through any sort of...
Oh no, no.
Okay, and then he retires
and goes off with the Rockefeller Foundation somewhere.
And they bring in President McVicar, Robert McVicar,
who was a one-man show.
There's no question about it.
A one-man show.
Turned out he was a member of our church.
And so at our annual church picnic, he was there with his wife,
and there was a OSU faculty member who was taking him around introduced.
And so I got introduced to him.
Well, it turned out that I had learned ahead of time that yes,
he was a graduate of the University of Wisconsin, his PhDs in biochemistry.
And a person who I actually taught my major professors course
to the undergraduate of Wisconsin.
And there was an individual who was on sabbatical from industry.
A man named Dave Perlman, who was just a gentleman.
And he gave the vitamin lectures in this course.
And somewhere along the line Dave Perlman told me,
oh, Mac, as McVicar was called.
And I were graduate students in the same lab in Madison.
Say hello to him.
And then Perlman later became dean of Wisconsin.
So here I am at median president of Vicar.
And I said, yeah, I know Dave Perlman.
Oh, and he's now keeping, he's both dean and maintain his research program.
And Mac's comment was, well, it's only dean of a pharmacy school.
I went back and told Dean Wilson, I said, you got a problem.
You got a big problem.
He did have a problem that turns out.
Well, he went on business retirement and so forth.
No matter everything he said, I've never heard of Mac firing anybody without due cause.
But what happened getting on back to my own personal.
I went up for promotion.
And it was turned down.
This happened to all over campus because he wanted a standard dossier
where you use outside referees.
Well, it threw my department, he didn't know what to do.
But to Wilson's credit, Dean Wilson's credit, who had been at Minnesota and at Texas.
He knew exactly where Mac was coming from and what had to be done.
And he says, okay, here is what we are going to do.
We've got the outline.
I need outside referees.
And so I may have professors at school's function.
And then I got, I did get promoted the next time around.
And then made it to professor on the first time around on that.
So, but that was happening all over campus.
And not only were young faculty in Shell Shock,
but you had department heads who had never been turned down all they did.
It was right, letters saying they wanted so-and-so promoted and tenured.
And it was done.
You had deans who had never been turned down.
And it was, how do you look back on your laugh?
But oh yeah, it was a traumatic time.
There was no question about it.
But the result was Oregon State University today.
And what I never have understood is why there's no building or anything like that named after him.
There are young faculty.
I have no idea who he, who Mac was.
And you gave him a lot of credit for propelling university for it.
Oh, I would say he, without him, we would still be second fiddle to the University of Oregon.
And I mean, real second fiddle.
I think Portland State could be ahead of us.
No, he knew what had to be done.
And he pushed.
And as I said, he is, as one person said, he was his own provost.
We had a dean of faculty in those days.
Dave Nicodemus, who was kind of the good cop.
And Mac was the bad cop as the president of university.
But I know, and he had quite a temper, boy, he could flare.
But I don't know if anybody who was out fired, who locked horns with him.
He just let fly.
But I just, I don't know if anybody who was, and I'm not saying there wasn't.
But he really followed protocol.
When we did not grant tenure to a faculty member, boy, he wanted to make sure everything was dotted.
And he reviewed it carefully.
I think one thing he didn't want to get lost, it was obviously.
But I think he, I think basically, have you ever read about this fellow who was present for a long time at Boston?
He did a Boston College or Boston University, Silverman, John Silverman.
And there's a review in the Wall Street Journal of a book he had written.
Well, he's dead now, so much a minute, a couple of years ago.
But he brought the school up into a major research university and hired top notch faculty.
And he believed in academic freedom.
But he also wanted to believe in excellence.
And it caused a real transformation.
And I kind of look at the two people.
Mac never wrote a book, as far as I know.
As the two of the same type, they had this goal and they know it could be done.
And if I get the right faculty, I know it can be done.
And he basically did.
What does he remember about him as a person that sounds like you knew him a little bit?
A little kind of a personal level.
He was very distant.
And I say we were in the same church and he just never seemed to let his guard down till after he retired.
He just lived over here.
A couple blocks away.
And one day after he retired.
I don't know if he's here with a petition for us to sign or what, but he showed up to the house.
Come on in.
He went down on the couch out there and just talked.
He even talked about being hired and things.
He'd yes.
Everything was fine.
He was retired now.
There was no barrier between us.
There was a neighborhood dessert from our church.
And we got the thing mixed up on the counter.
So my wife knocked.
I pushed a doorbell and they said, well, we're here for the dessert.
Well, that was last night or last week.
Oh gosh.
He said, come on in.
I think we have some pie.
We have some cake.
And his life is always very gracious.
And we sat down to visit for a while.
Well, what other colleagues of yours were important to you in OSU within pharmacy or elsewhere?
Well, there was that my department had Bob Dorby, who was very good.
The one that we were basically parallel to each other was George Constantine.
Who's here?
I mean, he's over at Albany, but he's not the one you could always interview.
Let's see.
As far as contemporaries, I would say those two for the most part.
And doing some research on the pharmacy is sort of more recent here.
Is that a couple of names that have stood out as people who have made an impact?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm going to speak one more.
The dean who, the gentleman who replaced Charlie Wilson was Dick O'Call.
Who was there for a long time?
Yes.
And he once, he, he said, John, how would you like to be on the Board of Pharmacy?
And I thought, okay, that sounds like an intriguing deal because I wasn't setting the world on fire research-wise.
And this is a State Board of Pharmacy.
Yes, a State Board of Pharmacy.
So I think I put my name in and the old guard in the profession that I'm a faculty member on the Board of Pharmacy.
It's ridiculous.
And the vacancy came up again.
He says, let's make another run at it.
And I don't know what I have behind the scenes, but I got appointed at the Board of Pharmacy.
Neil Goldschmidt.
Now, he didn't know me from Adam.
It's all done by the appointments office.
And they, of course, checked politics.
The Board of Pharmacy, I'm sure, was not on the Goldschmidt's political radar screen.
So I got on the Board.
And there was an executive director on the Board, Ruth Vanderbier, at a real vision where pharmacy could go.
She had basically been the author of the Revise Pharmacy Practice Act, which gave pharmacists a lot more responsibility in the state.
And I started to go to the National Association of the Board of Pharmacy and regional meetings.
I ended up offering a couple of resolutions, got on to task force of the Board.
I ended up being on one of the permanent committees of the National Association Board of Pharmacy on one of the exam committees for foreign pharmacy graduates.
So that, that, I would say Dick had a real impact.
I was on the Board for the mandatory eight years.
When I say mandatory, it can't exceed eight years.
And most President of the Board, twice.
I was going to ask you about a couple of fellows from the pharmacy department or the school of pharmacy.
It sounded like it made an impact through their research.
And one of them is James Ayers.
Oh, yes, yes.
He was on sabbatical somewhere.
And I got a call from Professor Sandin, a microbiology.
And I want to say it's Bill Sandin, but I may have the first name wrong, but anyway, Sandin.
And he wanted some way to develop some method of buffering bacterial cultures in the cheese making process.
And I said, well, the formulation person is Jim Ayers.
And so Jim comes back and they meet each other and they kept quite a collaboration going and had one of the most successful patents of that era.
And Jim may still, and I don't know if the college is still getting some money.
Of course, Jim getting some money.
This is the time release.
Time release, yes, right.
Yeah, Jim had, he had, he developed industrial contacts.
He probably had one of the biggest graduate programs.
He believed he's completely retired on the coast now.
And he no longer have a home here in Corvallis.
How about William Gerwig?
Oh, yes, yes.
He and I actually co-taught in the biochemistry course.
But Bill developed a fabulous natural products and was eventually hired away by the University of California at San Diego.
But he had a large program, a very large program.
He took a sabbatical in 1972, called Jurassic.
Yes.
Only about that.
Well, I wouldn't take a sabbatical, you know, people do.
So we arranged for the house to be rented by, I think, a couple that was on sabbatical from somewhere else.
And went down, stayed rented a house by an interesting older Polish couple,
who had not been back to Poland since the Second World War.
And I think family there.
So I worked in Karl Terassi's lab.
He's quite an individual.
And of course the father's birth control pill, so on.
And got four papers out.
It was a natural products lab.
Because without we were going to get really Sea Grant going.
And we had various ideas.
And somehow we never could tap into that well into the Sea Grant money here.
But we thought we'd get a marine natural products thing going.
It never did work out.
But yeah, it was a good year.
Did you get to know him very well?
He's one of these people that has a fantastic memory.
So he got to know you more than you got to know him.
I mean, I was working on one of the papers.
And I said, I bend the cam abstracts.
I'm not finding this reference.
He got up and went over to his card file.
Pulled out something from don't ask how all that paper was says here.
And he didn't do it in a way that I felt like shrinking in the floor.
And I don't know how I missed this.
Well, obviously I did.
You didn't have computerized search in the cam abstracts in those days.
It was all done manually with big thick volumes and fine print.
But anyway, he came up here once he retired as a chemist
and has written three or four novels and some plays.
Sort of a Renaissance man, I'd have to say.
And he came up, I can't remember who brought him up.
But I went over during a break and reintroduced myself.
He seemed to remember who I was.
He was friends with Linus Pauling who was also in the Stanford area at the time.
Yeah, and I can't remember if I did go over here when Pauling's lectures were not.
Pauling came back to campus a few times too.
You know, it was you.
Yes, oh yeah.
And the only time I heard him on campus that I'm aware of,
I can't remember if I went to any of the peace lectures later on.
The end after it made his wife.
But there was that one time when the Afro-American football players walked off the campus
because of the beard incident with, er, and moustache incident with Deandreus, the football coach.
And Pauling was to speak at Gil Colosseum.
And the students came in and Jensen was president.
It was a, it was an awkward situation.
And I think Jensen felt very hurt by that because I think Bacy was a very fair man.
But you're dealing with a powerful football coach who had powerful alumni behind him.
So it was an awkward situation.
And I probably went ahead and gave his talk.
You mentioned Dean Oval.
He was a Dean for 22 years, the longest serving Dean of his generation in pharmacy, apparently.
It sounds like there were at least a couple of changes that he invoked.
And one of them you mentioned a little bit was that emphasis on increased experience in patient care.
Well, that was going on during the, er, I would say that that was a trend in pharmacy education
all across the United States.
I knew it was very, I mean, it was going to make sure we stayed current.
As part of that, the curriculum added clinical components.
Can I ask you to turn that off?
And I'll tell you why.
Act two.
So we were talking about changes in the curriculum and the focus on clinical components, including communication skills.
Yeah, the history of communication has been a very interesting one.
For a long time, the pre-pharmacy curriculum had some type of speech requirement.
And the question was always, what is the appropriate type of speech requirement?
Is it it?
So I think the word expository speech, where you get up and give your three-minute speech, or your five-minute speech.
Which is not what pharmacists do.
They talk one and one like you and I are talking to each other.
And so what you want is, they're apparently, it was a speech course.
It's supposed they was more how to interact one-on-one rather than with an audience.
I'm not sure if there's still a speech requirement in the pre-pharmacy curriculum or not.
It wasn't there when I was an undergraduate, I can tell you that.
I had it in high school.
But what happened was, was mandatory counseling.
In fact, I was on the Board of Pharmacy when the mandatory counseling requirement went in.
And it was happening across the United States.
Part of it was patient, better patient care.
Part of it was, get the pharmacists out there talking with the patient,
rather than hiding behind the counter and having some sales clerk down there at all.
So, one of our, well I guess you call them factoring,
the fact that Mary's the director of student health service pharmacy, Bill Boyce,
and actually pioneered the technique for how to consult a patient.
And there's a little card and there's three questions on it.
I can't remember how they went.
But basically it was, what did your physician tell you about this medicine?
So, your first of all rather than get through this lecture,
I mean you're trying to find out what the patient's understanding.
So, you're not talking down to them.
And that's also a good way to do an error check into the last minute.
Because if you're handing them an antibiotic and the patient says,
it's for my high blood pressure, you know, just hang on a moment.
We've got to check this out.
But okay, we'll assume it's the correct prescription.
Another question might be, what did the,
and you could elaborate on the response or, yes, I see you have a good understanding.
What did the physician explain to you on how to take it?
And you find out, do they realize they are to take it?
Four meals or two hours after a meal.
And I can't remember if the third one,
whether you have any other question you want to ask me,
or did the physician explain any of the pertinent side effects?
And there you're trying to, you're not trying to scare the patient,
or they'll never take it.
But you might also, or if you do get a certain type of sensation,
you need to either call your physician or call us
rather than simply go up and give them a spiel.
You're trying to teach that type of communication on a one-on-one basis.
Most of the pharmacies are not even set up for it,
so you're trying to have some place in a corner where nobody else can hear the conversation.
But depending on the noise of the story is,
Fred Meyer, they probably can't hear it because of all the noise.
Ryze, I think you can hear the conversation.
I have a silly question.
I probably wouldn't even ask before it.
The pharmacists interpret the handwriting of doctors and the scripts that they receive.
A lot of it is practice.
A lot of it is now electronic transmission.
And one of the most important things is phone and find out what it is that was written.
So there isn't any secret code?
No, no.
And they're not supposed to write in a Latin anymore.
In fact, they don't write in a Latin.
It's kind of living through your career.
Well, one of the resolutions, and we finally got through the National Association of Borders of Pharmacy,
was the test of spoken English.
Not written English.
They're supposed to do that also.
spoken English was very interesting to see the opposition.
And of course, there was all this about a political correctness,
but you had to explain that the communication media
is you could have a resident at a medical center
who is from one country in Asia,
talking to a pharmacist who is from India.
And the only thing they've got in common is the English language.
Not saying the Asian one maybe that is good in English is the Indian one.
The point is airline pilots and the control towers use English.
So now if a pharmacist is dual language,
so they can talk in another language and explain the directions,
or hand the person a information sheet in the patient's native language,
some of the computer programs will do that.
Great, that's excellent.
But still got to be able to speak it.
I want to ask you about you served on a National Science Foundation panel
for instructional scientific equipment.
I did, you're right.
I've gotten about that.
Yeah, I was down in, I think Los Angeles,
I think we all went down there.
It was for undergraduate research,
and it was a very interesting panel.
And I'm not quite sure how my name got in there.
God, I never got funded by it.
I'm not sure if I replied.
But what was fascinating was you had good, solid liberal arts schools,
the Louis and Clark, and this date the Louis and Clarks,
the reads, the Williamins, for example, applying for,
they wanted a new NMR, a new updated infrared spectrum,
putometer for their lab.
They would be used and they would outline the courses that would be used in,
and also how it would function for undergraduate research projects.
And they would also be able to show how they would be able to support the instrument
that they had the technicians available to keep it going or experience faculty.
And you'd fund those.
Then you would get a little small liberal arts college
that maybe had one chemist, two of they were lucky,
who wanted this fancy piece of equipment.
And you say, how are they going to maintain it?
Do you understand how it works?
Where is the course that's going to be used in?
We wouldn't fund it.
Or you got the application from the chemistry department at the University of California,
or the University of Wisconsin and Madison,
who just had to have a new hot shot NMR,
and they were going to let the undergraduates walk by essentially.
No, we didn't fund that either.
So we basically funded liberal arts program.
Well, it didn't have to be, I'm sorry, I don't want to imply it had to be a private liberal arts school.
A school like Western probably would not have any problem either.
They had to have a substantial, we were doing it in the chemistry area now please.
Keep that in mind, speaking of the discipline.
They had to have a core of faculty.
One thing that really helped them was,
did they have a program that met the undergraduates of the American Chemical Society,
which means they had to have, and that had basically faculty in each of the disciplines,
organic, physical, analytical.
The seemingly important point in the modern history of the College of Pharmacy came in 1988
when the satellite campus was formed at OHSU.
That is still a dynamic situation.
The Oregon State, like some of the other pharmacy schools of history,
historical, are not out on a campus where there is a medical center.
And then the big debate is, does the school move to where the medical center is,
or is the school stay where it is and try to do the satellite campus?
And of course, we did the latter.
Part of it is, how would you move our whole research emphasis and productivity?
We are very productive.
If you take a look at the amount of grant money,
this pharmacy school is now bringing in.
Where would, how would it be situated?
Where would be the support infrastructure?
I mean, there's quite a dynamic support all across campus.
There's the mass spec centers, there's the NMR centers, and so forth.
So there's a real good synergism on a campus like this.
And so how would that be handled in Portland area?
Because there's not a major, excuse me, Portland state,
but there's not a major research university there.
Portland state has got some real strong areas, don't please don't misunderstand me.
And OHSU is a medical center.
They're not teaching the basic science courses that would feed into a medical center.
The students all come in for somewhere else.
So that's one thing.
So initially was to get the clinical program established up there for the fourth year
and try to get rotations.
And that took a lot of missionary work, you might say,
to get the medical center to accept it.
It seems to be working very well now.
It really is.
And of course, there's both the medical center, OHSU, and there is the VA.
And there's the other big hospitals,
legacy, Providence, Kaiser.
There is, I'm trying to think of basic pharmaceutical sciences.
And I have the impression that one of the sizes is only an impression
that there is some pharmaceuticals now up in Portland,
as opposed to just the clinical.
Well, another important moment came 11 years later,
when OHSU decided no longer to offer the bachelor's degree in pharmacy
and focus solely on the farm D.
Oh, yes, that's got a very interesting history.
The question was, was money for one thing to find answer,
because you need an additional faculty, particularly in the clinical area.
And you had to pay going wages,
because they could all work in the private sector.
So the question came up, and I remember Dick talking of a dickhole home,
talking about it, was, do we start a small farm D program,
and just kind of shoehorn it in.
And there was some type of educational coordinating committee
that was they had to approve new programs,
that would eliminate duplication.
I think it's passed by the wayside now.
And the chair of that committee made the comment.
He says, no, you wait until we can have a good program.
We want excellent program.
The other thing they did at the state level was saying,
you can't have a professional doctor program unless the students
have a bachelor's degree.
And there are these pharmacy schools, unfortunately, in my opinion.
A student can go through and get a doctor pharmacy degree
and not have any bachelor's degree.
Well, can you imagine a medical physician not having a bachelor's degree?
As far as I know, as Dennis do, I think all the lawyers now have bachelor's degree
before they get their doctor, jurisprudence.
And so, we worked out essentially a seven-year program.
Three-year pre-farmacy.
We made arrangements with general science
that they would accept courses in the first professional year,
maybe some in the second, towards the general science degree.
So, if they don't have a bachelor's degree,
they will by the end of their second professional year,
and they have to, before they take their last two years.
Now it turns out, I believe, over 90% are coming in with bachelor's degrees now.
But we were one of the first schools to require this bachelor's degree requirement.
I think Ohio State was coming to the other OSU, ironically,
or coincidentally, or whatever.
I believe the University of California, San Francisco,
is always, oh, I should say we're one of the first.
I think they always, they're one of the pioneers for the FarmD program.
And I think they always require a bachelor's degree.
I think they always did.
And that may have been true of USC also.
My understanding is a large number of the state pharmacy schools,
the well-established state, you know, at the state universities,
are now, have got so much in their pre-farmacy that,
essentially, there's a bachelor's degree requirement.
I don't know about Pacific, for example,
a person who didn't walk in office three to four years or a year later,
actually, they have a year around curriculum, three and a half years,
walk out with a farm degree without a bachelor's degree.
I don't know, frankly.
Well, it sounds like that this shift to the pharmacy
led to an even closer entire of the way.
Yes, you became a degree between the two universities.
Because it required more clinical faculty,
it required more clerkships,
and more making more rounds than that.
Yes, yes.
There's no question about it.
I want to talk a little bit more about your career.
You mentioned your time on the Oregon Board of Pharmacy.
One of the interesting things that you were involved with there was
assisting with the interpreting and implementation of the plan
for assisted suicide law.
I want to talk about that.
Yes!
That was a fascinating experience.
Here was a situation.
You had the potentiality of a pharmacist who was opposed to it,
receiving a prescription
and not realizing why they were dispensing it.
And in fact, they, under the patient constant,
they make a lot and give a bunch of goofy advice.
And may not even realize what was happening.
And then you had the situation where they had,
and I'm not going to dispense this and pull it back.
So, there were various scenarios.
The sponsors of the Physician-Sister Suicide
made no, if Hanson buts about it,
there was to be nothing hidden from the pharmacist,
nurses, anybody who could be an open process,
anybody who did not want to participate,
needing, and they actually had networks of physicians and pharmacists
and nurses, so forth, who were positive.
They could always put a family in touch,
get them into the system.
So, we went back and forth with the Board of Medical Examiners.
No, no, scratch that.
We went back and forth with the Oregon Medical Association.
It turned out that we've seen pretty well have the support
of the physicians, including the officers,
but there was a lobbyist who has taken his cue
from the American Medical Association
and if a physician doesn't want to tell the pharmacist
anything, that's it.
God has spoken.
And so, we finally wrote a rule that said physicians
had to tell the pharmacists.
Well, all of a sudden you had the Board of Pharmacy
write a rule covering the pharmacists.
The Board of Medical Examiners were not upset
because they couldn't get it.
They were being shoved, not pushed, not to.
And we now had our rule.
And the physician, the Oregon Medical Association,
they're lobbyists, didn't like it at all.
So, of course, by this time I believe Dr. Kitsopper
was governor.
And so, we, in the meantime,
we were trying to get through a collaborative drug treatment
through which we had a trained general
who says we had the authority to do,
but the drug industry didn't like it.
And this is where pharmacists can be involved
in working out the treatment modalities
and the dosage and so forth.
So, another Board member and I were called into
the governor's health advisor office.
And basically what the governor did,
he told the medical board,
you take that Board of Pharmacy Rule
and you rewrite it with your name on it,
instead of their name,
and you push it through which they did.
If that there was a draft and we approved it,
that was fine.
We didn't care.
All we wanted was the pharmacists
to call that these prescriptions were coming through.
And so, we told the health advisor,
that's fine with us.
And then he says,
so what now is it you're trying to do?
And we mentioned collaborative drug therapy.
And this fellow head was a former EMT
or something on the ambulance.
That's how he knew Kitsopper.
They were fishing buddies from Southern Oregon.
And he looked and says,
well, is that like when I'm on the ambulance,
I start the IV.
And for a person in cardiac arrest,
and said, yeah, he says,
oh, okay, you got it.
I'll tell the lobbyist from the OMA
that it's going to go through.
So we got what we wanted,
and the physicians got,
well, they know they got what they wanted,
but at least they have face saving on it.
So yeah, that's the story.
We're all happy campers now.
You mentioned, too,
that you started on the foreign pharmacy graduate equivalency examination committee.
Yeah, that's the exam committee
with the National Association Board of Pharmacy.
What did that entail?
Oh, you had a significant number
of graduates of foreign pharmacy schools
that wanted to immigrate
to the United States in practice pharmacy.
And we had no,
there's no equivalent of a basic pharmacy medical exam,
basic medical science exam.
There's something that medical schools have
after a couple of years,
I guess everybody takes this test
before they go out in the clinch.
I'm really not quite sure how it works,
but there apparently is some type of standard test.
There's nothing like that with pharmacy.
So this is the closest thing to it.
And there's other requirements for the graduate.
They've had to have so many years
in a pharmacy school
that has to meet certain curricular standards
and so on.
And there is a test of spoken English,
by the way, they have to pass.
And of course,
the test of English
or the foreign language,
they have to pass that also.
So basically,
there's a bank of questions
that we work on,
I have to be in the medicinal chemistry area.
That's supposed to be equivalent
to what,
if they can pass it,
then they have at least the minimum standards
of graduating in the dike-dactic coursework
in a pharmacy school.
Now, they still have to do their interning
and that sort of thing.
So I was in the medicinal chemistry
we meet twice a year.
We would come up with questions
just like SATs,
any of these questions
that are on there that are going to count
and there's questions that are being tested
to see if they're discriminating
or they're too difficult,
or they're too easy.
And so we would be working on new questions
plus trying to fix the questions
that didn't test right.
And one of the things I did was
in the pioneer,
as they developed this exam,
the chemistry portion,
some of the chemical structures
were pretty bad.
They were bad.
So I said,
well, I've got a ChemDraw program,
which was sort of the standard.
And so I worked out a deal with them.
I didn't get paid,
but I redrew hundreds and hundreds of structures
using the same program.
Something else that you worked on
that is interesting to me
and my background with Linus Pauli,
he developed them all for General Amesthesia.
And I understand that that's something
you studied to the controversy
over General Amesthesia.
Well, that's one of the contracts
with the Army.
And we were trying to see
if there was a receptor forward.
I think there is,
because they've got optically active,
stereotypical,
sit left and right,
and molecules,
one is active,
the other is not.
So there must be some type of receptor.
But that never led to anything.
Do I understand correctly
there is still no accepted theory
of why General Amesthesia was?
I think there is some theories for it,
but there's some about nerve conduction
where it's going depolarization
and neurons.
I think there is some of that now,
because they can visualize the brain
so much differently nowadays,
with the various types of scans,
the PET scanners,
and all that,
but they can get some idea
which neurons are firing,
which part of the brain
is reacting in certain ways.
So I think they're closer.
We retired in 2003 after 37 years
in the College of Pharmacy,
and we saw a lot of change,
and we reflected on the changes
in the college over that,
of course, at that time.
Well, I mean,
we've been talking about them,
but BC has started out to be a traditional five-year
bachelor degree program,
medicinal chemistry,
pharmaceutical analysis,
formulation,
for basic pharmaceuticals,
what they called physical pharmacy,
dosing standard,
classic pharmacology,
and they were still teaching pharmacy management
if you're going to have your own drug store.
So I think there was some accounting in there,
and as it became more and more obvious
that pharmacists were going to be employees,
you saw the management evolved
into pharmacy socioeconomic,
so you started,
they started to be the discussion
of healthcare delivery,
which population groups
can get it,
and why,
which ones cannot get it,
and why not,
various types of insurance models out there,
then, as I said,
the labs disappeared
as far as the pharmaceutical sciences went.
There is still...
I think they still do a little bit of compounding,
some basic compounding,
but I think that's about it,
and I'm not even sure it's a small lab
and they got some sterile hoods,
and I think that's about all they're doing.
I think,
I may be wrong on that,
you'd have to ask somebody,
like the associate dean or somebody to ask them.
Big emphasis on patient care,
big emphasis on the clinical pharmacy aspect,
which is person has a certain disease
or a couple of diseases,
and this drug causes this side effect,
and this drug,
and our person shows up,
and they're taking six or eight,
and I'm not exaggerating,
six or eight different drugs,
and cannot be whittled down to three or four,
because they take a drug,
they get a side effect,
they get a drug to treat the side effect,
and so on,
gets messy.
Of course,
with the area diabetes,
just use as an example,
not used to be basically insulin,
and a couple oral medications,
well, there's several oral,
and there's a whole bunch of other drugs
that have been discovered
that affect the pancreas,
that affect the alpha cells,
or the beta cells,
and then there's even looking at the auto-eminology aspect
of it all on the clinical side.
I know that one of the pursuits
that you've followed retirement
is you're going to your Medicare resource.
Yeah, and this date is called
Shiba Senior Health Benefit Assistance Program,
which that notebook is sitting over there
and you're beside you there.
Nationally, it's SHIP,
Senior Health Insurance Assistance Program,
which the A haven't been dropped.
Until very recently,
we were part of Center
for Medicare and Medicaid Services.
I'd have to go to the computer
and find out who the new federal agency is we're on.
We are moving under,
I don't guess the move is not complete yet.
And I'm not sure,
politically, what the heck was going on
and we got moved.
But we go...
I started back in 2005
when the Part D drug programs began.
A person who was the coordinator
was looking for volunteers desperately
because they needed people to put the drugs
into what was called Medicare.gov plan finder
and find out what Part D plan would work for them
and as retired from pharmacy.
So I've been better than ever since.
I was Shiba Lite for a couple of years
and then full.
I think I'm the Senior One in Ben County.
Now, I believe.
Anyway,
we are, of course,
go through training.
We have to be recertified every year.
We go through a background check,
which includes fingerprinting.
Obviously, we've signed all the confidentiality agreements.
We log every contact.
It goes into a,
obviously, a secure database
and our password changes every two months.
I also am one of the instructors.
We either call it new to Medicare
or ABCDs of Medicare,
Part A, Part B, Part C, Part D.
It's like a...
And that's a two-hour free course.
Most of them are taught over here at the Benton Center
because they have the parking
and they have the classroom
with computer facilities.
And I'm currently on phone duty now.
Oh, I should explain.
If you have a Medicare question
or you want to talk to a counselor,
there's two ways of doing it.
One is to call the toll-free number
and say them,
which you can get off of the web,
or to get Shiba in.
And we can take it right there.
And you punch in your zip code
and it automatically is referred then to Albany.
We, our sponsor here is RSVP,
Retire Senior Volunteer Program.
And the sponsors for the different Shiba slash ships,
very important,
it's not known to County Department of Health,
I guess, is their sponsor.
And I can't tell you who the sponsors are
and other counties.
Lynn and Benton and Lincoln are together.
But anyway,
you'll go into the RSVP office
at the Consulate Government's Office
on Queens Avenue over there in Albany.
And then an email will go out to the appropriate county
with referral.
And I'm on phone duty.
And the main reason for that is,
as I can't verify,
may have mentioned,
when you came in.
My wife is on foster home,
and she's actually under hospice,
so I go up three times a day
and feed her,
excuse me,
and I can't get up to the senior center.
So I get the referrals
and so forth.
Which is kind of interesting.
I kind of like that.
I enjoy it.
Almost better than,
I don't mean anti-face to face,
but you can,
you can get quite a bit of information
over the phone.
And we have,
we have Google Calendar
to make appointments I can even make an appointment for them.
It's just a seemingly complicated subject
to be dealing with.
One of the things we mentioned in our classes,
and we'll tell clients
when they almost are feeling sheepish.
When you, we worked,
and you had employer health insurance,
you took the employer plan.
That was it.
I mean, you might have had a choice
to do in a high deductible,
but basically that was it, folks.
And they may or may not have had dependency coverage.
Okay, now you're reaching 65.
What are you going to do?
Are you going to keep working?
Or as your company or your employer says,
fine.
If then are you going to draw social security or not?
And a lot of people think,
well, if I don't draw social security,
I don't go into Medicare.
And no, wrong.
At age 65, you have got to enroll in Medicare,
or you're going to get penalized.
And the penalties can be significant, by the way.
Unless you happen to be an employer group health plan
of 20 or more employees.
At which case, you can delay it.
So Medicare has been described as yes,
no, and with the following exceptions.
But it is universal health care single payer
for the over 65 and over, and for disabled.
It interfaces with private insurance
to pick up deductibles and co-insurance.
And this is where a lot of people then,
should I go with a Medicare supplement,
known as a Medicare, or should I go with an advantage plan?
And if I decide to go with an advantage plan,
which one should I go with?
If I decide to go with a Medicare, which one should I go with?
So there are these various.
And then there's the fall open enrollment period,
where people can change plans.
And now with the Affordable Care Act,
the Medicare crowd also start making appointments
because they see all this publicity on the Affordable Care Act.
They want to know how this affects them.
It doesn't.
Well, it does.
But there's nothing they can do about it.
Well, the effect is basically beneficial.
The donut hole will slowly disappear in in the Part D.
So there's a clue I need for people like you.
So help people navigate.
Oh, it keeps us mentally alert, orally straight.
Well, I'll just take a couple more questions for you.
The new building in Portland just opened up.
I haven't seen it, but they say it's very nice.
And I said, the other tower,
then it's beautiful view of the river.
They could even watch the barges being watched.
You know that.
But I have not seen the new one,
other than dry by it.
So it's going up.
It strikes me as being another important chapter,
I guess, in the history of pharmacy.
I think they work very, they being the current Dean
and the previous Dean.
Worked very hard to make sure we had the floor space
and the labs, and so forth,
to be a fully not move us there,
but to make sure that the faculty there had resources
and are to advance.
A number of them are hired as clinical assistant,
clinical associate professors.
That's a non-tenure track type of deal with revolving,
fixed term type of thing.
But they're a tenure track faculty up there too.
The last thing I want to ask you about
is that the university has changed so much
in the last few years,
and continues to change and grow.
That's a good year.
Perspective on where I always see his heading right now.
Well,
I have the impression that we want to be
the strongest university in the state,
which I have no problem with.
We are, of course, in every county.
I think our relationship with the state is quite good.
The amount of extramural funding that we bring in is phenomenal.
It's not just NIH, I mean there's ag,
there's sea grant, all that type of thing.
I think the question that OSU has to really wrestle with
as do any research university
is
making sure that the undergraduate still has a good education experience,
which at a good research university they can.
You have good students
and you can get them involved in the searching out at new knowledge.
It can be a fabulous, fabulous experience.
But the faculty
have to want to enjoy working with undergraduates.
Not just their graduate students and their postdocs.
And for that young assistant professor,
that can be,
that can be a time-telling, that can be a strain.
Because it's hard to get the funding.
I mean, back in the days when the funding was more plentiful,
it probably wasn't, but I mean they are struggling to bring that money in.
And they're hired now with fairly generous start-up packages
and they return the university wants them to produce.
It might almost pay it back.
So it's a rough go.
And I have to be very candid
and say,
would I today start out
the same way?
I think pharmacy was fine.
And with the clinical pharmacy and so forth,
I might find it
more,
I'm more interesting.
Many more instincts, the wrong word.
But I don't know if I would like to be under that constant gun of getting funded
and get it renewed.
I still think that's my temperament.
I felt very fortunate that Dick O'Bullock took me under his wing there
and said, why didn't you?
I think he saw it was going to fill in big bucks.
Why, if you look at the regulatory.
And I think I was successful there.
Well, Dr. Bock, thank you very much.
This has been very educational for me.
And I appreciate you giving us this time to share your memories of pharmacy.
Well, thank you for coming.
And whatever I said, I'll be dying.
All right, thanks.